[Music]
thank you Jesus welcome here gathered at
London's High Court Refugee campaigners
awaiting a ruling on legal challenges to
the British government's stated aim to
send the vast majority of people seeking
asylum in the UK automatically to Rwanda
to have their claims processed and if
successful to be settled there
for the most part the judges found in
favor of the government Lord Justice
Lewis writing we have concluded that it
is lawful for the government to make
arrangements for relocating Asylum
Seekers to Rwanda and for their Asylum
claims to be determined in Rwanda rather
than the UK however the Home Secretary
must consider properly the circumstances
of each individual claimant
the Court ruled that had not been done
in the case of eight individual Asylum
Seekers whose deportation to Rwanda was
called off in June after the European
Court of Human Rights intervened people
will have watched this judgment
carefully today and they will know now
that there is a legal route open to them
to challenge any of the decisions made
by the home office and between that
situation and the possibility of appeals
moving forwards no one should think that
this litigation is going away anytime
soon
certainly allowing individuals to
challenge deportation to Rwanda would
undermine the government's claim that
the policy would deter them from trying
to get to the UK in the first place this
year the number of people making the
short but dangerous Crossing from France
is up more than a third at around 45
000 people speaking in Latvia Britain's
prime minister welcomed the ruling what
I want to deliver is a system whereby if
you come to the UK illegally you will
not have the right to stay and we will
be able to return you to your own
country if it's safe or a safe
alternative like Rwanda that's a common
sense position I think of the vast
majority of the British public it's my
position and that's what I want to
deliver as prime minister the various
organizations who are challenging the
government policy have of course
expressed their deep disappointment at
this ruling but they're also saying that
the road is far from run on an
individual basis Asylum Seekers will
still be able to challenge their
deportations to Rwanda and as far as the
generic decision is concerned there may
well be grounds for appeal I welcome the
Judgment from the high court today the
British Home Secretary has in the past
called for Britain to leave the European
convention on human rights to allow it
more freedom to act if any appeal
against this ruling were to succeed in
the European Court it would leave her
colleague the Prime Minister whose
studiously avoided that question with a
difficult decision to make Harry Fawcett
Al Jazeera London